heute sprechen wir über die drei wörter
weil denn und da diese wörter können
manchmal verwirrend für euch sein denn
alle drei wörter werden mit because
übersetzt
darum sprechen wir heute mal darüber was
der unterschied zwischen den dreien ist
und wann und wie man sie benutzt weil
denn und da haben eines gemeinsam sie
sind alle drei konjunktionen eine
konjunktion verbindet immer zwei sätze
oder zwei satzteile miteinander
es gibt zwei arten von konjunktionen es
gibt einmal neben ordnende konjunktionen
die verbinden zwei hauptsitze
miteinander die nebeneinander
gleichberechtigt sind und es gibt
sogenannte unterordnen de konjunktionen
die verbinden immer einen hauptsatz und
einen nebensatz miteinander
dieser unterschied ist tatsächlich
wichtig denn je nachdem ob man eine
neben ordnende oder eine unterordnen de
konjunktion benutzt verändert sich auch
die satzstruktur denn zb ist eine neben
ordnende konvention
ich kann nicht arbeiten denn ich habe
kopfschmerzen weil ist eine unterordnen
de konjunktion ich kann nicht arbeiten
weil ich kopfschmerzen habe neben
ordnend bedeutet dass zwei hauptsätze
nebeneinander stehen
ich kann nicht arbeiten und ich habe
kopfschmerzen sind beides zwei
hauptsätze und sie haben auch die
gleiche satzstruktur subjekt werk objekt
und man kann diese beiden hauptsätze mit
einem denn verbinden und trotzdem bleibt
die satzstruktur gleich ich kann nicht
arbeiten denn ich habe kopfschmerzen
das kannst du den müll rausbringen
das geht nicht denn ich bin gerade
beschäftigt und später später geht es
auch nicht denn dann muss ich gitarre
spielen übrigens wenn ihr mehr zum thema
konjunktionen werden wollt dann checkt
mal unsere app ceiling aus dort haben
wir auch mehrere interaktive video
geschichten für euch vorbereitet in
diesen geschichten stellen wir euch die
verschiedenen konjunktionen vor und ihr
könnt auch selbst aktiv werden eure
stimme aufnehmen
eure aussprache üben und auch die
deutsche satzstruktur üben sie ist jetzt
verfügbar im googleplex tor und im app
store kommen wir jetzt zu den unter
ordnenden konjunktionen unterordnen
bedeutet dass es einen hauptsatz und
einen nebensatz gibt und diese
unterordnen konjunktionen zum beispiel
weil und da die leighton immer einen
nebensatz 1
das ist wichtig zu wissen denn in einem
nebensatz ist die satzstruktur anders
wir hatten am anfang des videos dieses
beispiel ich kann nicht arbeiten denn
ich habe kopfschmerzen denn verbindet
zwei hauptsätze und beide sätze haben
eine ähnliche satzstruktur wenn ich
jetzt weil oder da benutze dann
verändert sich die satzstruktur ich kann
nicht arbeiten weil ich kopfschmerzen
habe ich kann nicht arbeiten da ich
kopfschmerzen habe ihr seht hier steht
das verb das konjugierte wert am ende
des lebens satzes janus könntest du
vielleicht staub saugen kann ich leider
nicht weil ich keine zeit habe
warum hast du keine zeit
ich habe keine zeit weil ich was
wichtiges machen was machst du denn
wichtiges das kann ich dir nicht so
jetzt sag schon
ich muss noch diese 50 tags bei youtube
durcharbeiten und wie wäre es mit heute
abend das ist schlecht da ich schon was
vor
was hast du denn vor gitarre spielen
jetzt fragt ihr euch bestimmt was ist
denn eigentlich der unterschied zwischen
weil denn und da und wieso gibt es drei
wörter dafür warum es genau drei wörter
gibt kann ich auch nicht sagen aber
tatsächlich gibt es einen unterschied im
gefühl wenn man was benutzt weil ist
etwas was man häufiger in der
gesprochenen sprache benutzt und da und
denn würde man vielleicht häufiger in
der geschriebenen sprache benutzen
natürlich kann man auch weil schreiben
und man kann auch denn und da in der
gesprochenen sprache hören
aber grundsätzlich sind da und dann
vielleicht ein bisschen formella also
wenn ich zum beispiel einen
wissenschaftlichen text schreibe oder
einen journalistischen text dann klingt
es einfach besser wenn man da schreibt
statt weil der damen und herren da ich
mit ihrem produkt äußerst unzufrieden
bin möchte ich mich beschweren
ansonsten gibt es keinen echten
unterschied wenn ihr euch fragt welches
wort soll ich denn benutzen
in der gesprochenen sprache ist weil mit
sicherheit immer eine gute wahl
und wenn ihr aber vielleicht einen
formellen text schreibt dann klingt da
auch nicht schlecht und das letzte was
ihr euch merken ist ist natürlich dass
ihr wissen müsst welche konjunktion
neben ordnend ist und welche unterordnen
ist und dafür gibt es auch eine ganze
liste
man muss das einfach auswendig lernen
und dann die satzstruktur üben ich
verlinke ich meine liste hier unten in
der infobox wenn ihr auch mal ein thema
habt was ihr ganz schwierig findet im
deutschen oder wo er eine frage habt
dann schreibt uns gerne einen kommentar
wir freuen uns immer über eure
themenvorschläge und vielleicht machen
wir dann nächstes mal ein thema für euch
und wenn ihr lust habt weiter mit
lustigen dialogen deutsch zu lernen dann
checkt unbedingt unsere app sie länger
aus sie ist jetzt im googleplex tor und
im app store verfügbar
tschüss und bis bald es ist noch nicht
später